a secure google cloud project is a happy
google cloud project
and a big part of maintaining that
security is securing your service
accounts
remember access to resources can be
granted to service accounts in the same
way that they can be granted to users
and not only are they designed to be
used by applications and virtual
machines
they can be accessed by other users too
that means that a service account that's
set up with access to too many resources
and that's accessible by too many users
introduces a serious vulnerability
so in this episode we'll talk about
what's what with securing your service
accounts roles and permissions
when thinking about securely managing
service accounts you could start by
asking
two questions what resources can your
service accounts access
and what permissions your service
accounts need
for example let's take this service
account with the editor role assigned
what resources can this service account
access
well with the editor role the answer is
pretty much all of them
okay so what permissions does this
service account need
the answer to that will depend on what
you need service account to do
and it's likely to be a lot less than
the permissions associated with the
editor
role this means that you'll have to
adjust the project's ian policy to
delegate the appropriate iam roles and
permissions
when you do that it's best to adhere to
the principle of leased privilege
that means signing to your service
account the minimum access required for
it to carry out its intended function
any account with permissions beyond what
it needs introduces an
unwanted security risk so steer clear of
assigning broad roles to your service
accounts like owner or editor especially
in a production environment
this is true even for default service
accounts that are created for you with
the editor role assigned right off the
bat
yeah it's useful for development but
make sure to narrow things down
when turning things up for production
applying the principle of least
privilege also means limiting which
users have access to your service
accounts
access to your service accounts can mean
different things since there are a
number of predefined iam roles that will
grant users permissions
over your service accounts in different
ways let's talk about some of these
service account related roles that might
impact your project security
first up we have the create service
account and
delete service account roles they allow
users to do exactly what those names say
create new service accounts and delete
existing service accounts
respectively it's worth noting that the
create role on its own doesn't let you
do
anything beyond creating a new service
account you'll need to be granted
additional permissions to make changes
to its rules
or to manage its iam policy likewise the
delete role
does not include the permissions to
undelete disable
or enable only delete service accounts
up next is a service account user role
with this role users are allowed to act
as a service account to run certain
operations
for example a user that has the
permission to create compute instances
cloud functions or app engine apps will
need the service account user role
assigned
so that they can attach a service
account to any of those resources
next there's service account admin a
user of this role can do all
administrative tasks on service accounts
enable them disable them delete them and
update their details
they can even make changes to the
service account iam policies
so a user of this role can delegate
access service accounts to other users
for that reason the service account
admin role is very powerful
and should be delegated very carefully
if at all
another administrative role for service
accounts is the service account key
admin role
users of this role will be able to
create and delete service account
private keys
these keys can be used by other users to
run commands as a corresponding service
account
as you can probably guess this can
become problematic
especially if you have a boatload of
keys floating around without an
effective way of tracking them
or managing their distribution this is
another role that you'll want to
delegate very carefully
and finally there is the service account
token creator
with this role a user is able to use the
impersonate service account flag to run
gcloud commands as a specified service
account
now this kind of impersonation doesn't
require the use of any private keys
and is considered a safer alternative
the service account token creator role
also lets users create oauth 2 access
tokens sign blobs
or generate self-signed json web tokens
the service account user admin key admin
and token creator roles i mentioned
could be granted to any account by
adding the binding to a project's iam
policy
but watch out by granting them on a
project's policy
it will grant those permissions on every
service account that exists on that
project
now this likely goes against the
principle of least privilege and
is generally not a great idea instead
you can avoid over delegating access to
service accounts by editing
individual service account iam policies
service accounts aren't just accounts
they're also considered resources
of an attached iim policy by binding
users to these roles on individual
service accounts
you will decrease the likelihood that a
user will make an accidental change
and substantially decrease the blast
radius if a user account is ever
compromised
do your best to grant users access only
to the service accounts that they
actually need
it's also worth noting that yes service
accounts can be granted these roles on
other service accounts
so take into account instances where a
user can have
indirect access to a service account
through another service account
you can see a service account's iam
policy with gcloud
im service accounts geti and policy
followed by a service account
by understanding the roles associated
with service accounts and by doing a
thorough review of your
iam policies to apply the principle of
least privilege you'll be taking major
steps towards maintaining a safe and
secure project
but that's not all even after you've
done that
there's still more you need to know
about securing your service accounts
next time we'll spend some time talking
about securely impersonating service
accounts
and effectively managing their private
keys see you there